now drewski you know we're very serious
journalists on his podcast yeah yeah so
we do our research yeah and I know that
you have a respect for journalism
because that's what you wanted to do
initially before you found common
research yes yes so I'm in here I'm
really doing the Deep Dives so my first
question for you is is why would you uh
jerk off at truck stop showers
that's pretty deep
yeah yeah yeah
the showers at the truck stop with the
sandals on your toes hanging off all
right man this that's such a dark time
man why do we have to breathe why is
that the first [ __ ] questions
yeah I get it um there was no glory hole
yeah it wasn't none of that it was
definitely dirty as [ __ ] in that [ __ ]
though man we I was on tour with Jack
Harlow yeah and literally like it's a
small tour man nobody was getting any
plate ah that [ __ ] goes like every every
morning though we had to take showers at
a new truck stop in a new city so it was
like the most [ __ ] of [ __ ] like
you're walking in there with your
sandals and like you're dropping your
soap that you have to bring in there and
like it was just some [ __ ] but
honestly yeah no that was those were
Dark Times notice how he said no one was
getting played yeah no yeah no yeah no
not just me yeah yeah
[Laughter]
now the other rumor is about you that
you are really attracted to women with
bad attitudes whoa oh [ __ ] yeah who's
where is these rumors coming from I just
just I heard you like a real like
sulking in the corner you know stank
face kind of is this true Jack must have
told you all this time I know I didn't
even I don't even know Jack I didn't
speak to Jack at all I didn't speak to
Jack about it
[Laughter]
but he believes that honestly he he says
like I have I I have something for women
with bad ideas I don't know what that is
what is it about like a woman looking
thing like an [ __ ] man like I can't
being too nice like women that are too
nice just like [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying like ah I'm just like the hell
with it because it's like the two nice
[ __ ] just gets cringed after a while
like oh my God baby baby baby all that
[ __ ] y'all get it so you want like a
croissant or something like that yeah
yeah
I think yeah at some point I may get
annoyed with that yeah but you like I'm
hateful yeah a little bit a little bit
I'm surprised you guys did your research
we know about these things um
yo we care about journalism for sure
he broke the Ukraine Story the war in
Ukraine I dropped out of school
of Journalism so oh well I jumped out of
school doing journalism
okay uh I just want to get a couple
other things out that I've kind of
learned about too because these were new
things that I had no clue about and this
is not necessarily from Jack these are
just things that I've heard about in
general okay
um my juice sounds like it's from Jack
yeah that last one did oh really yeah
yeah cause nobody else knows that I'm
just saying these are things that I've
come across okay read it probably yeah
um the word on the street is is you're
taking your entire family
to the whitest place on the planet
is
[ __ ] where are y'all
is that what that's true white condo you
said I promise you a white Christmas and
then you are literally delivering a
white Christmas like that no but I am
taking my whole family to Colorado for
Christmas
no the hood in Breckenridge yeah yeah
I've heard of that yeah yeah yeah yeah
and how it's a whole bunch of uh black
people there uh where but there will be
uh I think like like Veil veil's a very
very bad it is it is it is yeah you know
about it yo them ski slopes but yeah
it's crazy out there man you know what I
mean
the black diamonds
them black diamonds are dangerous who
told you all this stuff
you're a person of interest people are
gonna know about your life we're gonna
share that information
though that's like you take your fam to
Colorado for Christmas and and then
they're like we never won a Christmas
gift ever again
hell yeah I just thought there was some
[ __ ] that they believed that I
should still participate in the secret
Santa thing yeah in a relationship yeah
depart they're not coming you got a girl
my dad
Bros
yeah it's fairly new yo [ __ ] Jack Harlow
bro he's telling me all them goddamn
things it gave you bad information
God damn bro he told me one other crazy
thing I didn't believe this one that he
went to a 21 Savage party and then you
left with a hole in your pants by your
butthole what wow holy [ __ ] is that true
partially not by my [ __ ]
what else is terrible man now I know
[ __ ] you jack yeah
honestly now there's a hole in my pants
but it was like in this area you know
like but who is that market none of you
guys are fat
I'm not saying like a fat thing that's
kind of like you're not fat bro you guys
aren't like you carry it well a fat
thing in what way like explain like no
let's address what he just said
I was 38.00
[Laughter]
yeah you might as well say I'm thick
though yeah that's okay you can call
yourself I don't care in the front but I
got that [ __ ] in the back that's what he
said power bottom let's go
awesome
[Music]
tell us about that Savage party yeah it
was a 21 Savage Point not Savage
21 Savage birthday party and um it was I
think it was like 70s theme and like the
pants were like
like the the material is the material
yeah definitely right so um people were
skinnier back then
this idea and I just was getting groovy
man and my [ __ ] tore between the crotch
area yeah man I just we had to go home
after that for sure though yeah yeah
yeah yeah because it was pretty yeah
yeah pretty [ __ ] up situation did
other people know this was that like
Jack that's what I'm saying this is
[ __ ] up Jack yeah for real
fat people you can hide the the if it's
a hole in your pants because your thighs
are already rubbing was harder for fat
people
he's good
he's good watch out for now but
yeah watch your [ __ ] selfie
[Applause]
there's some melanin okay you were
saying that so I forgot that [ __ ]
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] he's a bad
guy come on I like how you got myself
yeah
[Applause]
on the couch bro come on brother you
know this is how he does it you know
this is how he does it right yeah wait
what this is what happened with Jack bro
yeah man you know he was originally
hosting these shows of Jack and then he
poured water all over the [ __ ] DJ
booth destroyed the whole goddamn show
you didn't know about this story you did
that yo remember
he didn't tell me that the girl told me
that the girl was so upset she was in
the corner said ruined this show and
you're like fine and then you went into
this so I'll tell you another story I'll
tell you that story so I thought early
on in our careers like I thought we were
so lit like I thought we were we could
Rave at the show that I was hosting yeah
whole time the show was so dead it's
like bro you shouldn't even come up here
and say a [ __ ] word just bring the
main act this is
yeah less than 100 maybe probably like
[ __ ] 50 to 70 people and I bring a
water bottle out there I was like
everybody let's [ __ ] God I started
throwing water but when I squeeze the
water
I throw it backwards
none of the water goes out like this
nothing comes out when I throw it there
it all went to the DJ dog
he was in the Splash Zone bro
it was honestly I'm a cute real that DJ
he's still pissed at me
he's still he never did [ __ ] with me
after that though pay him back ever nah
bro it was the end of the tour was it
drama that was like no it wasn't drama
oh okay damn that yeah that was yeah
Jack Jack told me that uh he got on
stage about to start the show in his
Mike just didn't work yeah
I [ __ ] everything up bro yeah yeah I
definitely [ __ ] that show up luckily
that was the last show on the tour I
think we were in North Carolina [ __ ]
North Carolina
okay get spicy bro why you hating
because we don't have a tour uh there
yeah you'll probably avoid it yeah
[Laughter]
you go
from internet obscurity to one of the
most famous people break down that word
[ __ ] that nobody knew you on the
internet before you blew the [ __ ] up
yeah that's how you started you can't be
careful though because that's what
you've been here yeah internet obscure
you're obscure you're that guy wants to
be a journalist yeah
[Laughter]
the point is you blow the [ __ ] up yeah
this this could have been records thing
yeah there could have been obscured it
could have been incredibly obscure
absolutely explode and then I hear an
interesting thing happens
I hear when you start doing these brand
collabs
the brands are shocked how many athletes
and entertainers want to do the shows
because you're involved yes did you know
about this yes that is like the biggest
thing that's crazy because it's very
rare that somebody goes from like
internet to working with the biggest
companies yeah I don't know people do it
I know that maybe there's like
especially with comedians yeah probably
just Drewsky brother I'm I'm actually
thinking about it
might just be
just be it might just be
are you Jewish
he owns a record label
[Music]
[Applause]
eternalism
we gotta sleep ourselves that's a Polish
name is very polish yeah dude derives
from Drew
and Drew rhymes with
oh